the Giudice family is finally back
together for that long-awaited reunion
overseas I'm happy that he's out like oh
my gosh you know I'm happy I'm happy
sprayed on Wednesday Theresa's 18 year
old daughter Gia shared this sweet
family shot with the caption we're back
yep there's the whole crew Theresa
Gabriella Jo Audriana Milania and Gia
prior to the family reunion gia shared
two videos from their travels including
this clip labeled JFK John F Kennedy
Airport and this video of a ton of
snacks alongside the caption flight
necessities now I'm hungry once the fan
touched down in Italy as she shared this
shot writing see you so soon daddy I
just want to let you know that I love
yous and you know I'm always here for
you Teresa has yet to post about the
trip but her family and co-stars have
had something to say about Gia's post
Teresa's brother Joe wrote yes love you
while her co-stars Dina and Delores
shared a heart and prayer emoji and
wrote love it Teresa did however share
this pic of herself with her 14 year old
daughter Milania on their trip promoting
the premiere of The Real Housewives of
New Jersey in the caption just three
days prior gia shared this snap of her
dad writing see you soon daddy my
daughters are doing well so hanging in
there they're doing good thank God
they're pretty amazing
you know strong young women I guess they
get it from their mommy almost a month
earlier Melania shared some family
photos to writing
see you soon daddy I love you beyond
words Jo is currently staying in Italy
as he waits for a decision to be made in
his deportation appeal at the end of the
day people make mistakes nobody's
perfect Jo was released from prison in
March after serving three years behind
bars after pleading guilty to multiple
charges of fraud in 2014 our family late
last month Teresa and Joe via satellite
both appeared in a special episode of
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
where they got candid about the trouble
in their marriage do I feel like he was
faithful
yeah no you don't know I don't like that
she took a photo with another man but I
mean I've asked her about the guy I mean
she says that he's I don't know this
friend I mean I don't know what kind of
fun may be you know I don't know and he
even asked about the future of their
marriage if Teresa decides to file for
divorce is there is there do you
understand why she would do that listen
as long as she's happy you know that's
all that really matters I mean I'm not
gonna you know tell her what to do I
can't you know I mean it's if she
doesn't feel like she wants to be with
me anymore then you know that's the
thing to do they're very vocal about the
state of their marriage about their
level of trust or lack of trust for each
other
what's to come I was really surprised
I've obviously interviewed that many
times and I was super surprised by their
candor and also where they're at with
each other which is a precarious place
no I don't know I think a lot is riding
on her trip to Italy to see him in a few
weeks
so that trip is here and we'll be
waiting to see how things go
Bravo cameras are following along for
the whole thing so we'll get to watch it
unfold on Real Housewives of course you
can count on ET to spill all the
housewife tea so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]